[Music]
hey guys a few months ago the most
reliable source regarding the leak plots
and all the leaks in general has shared
a few shock informations regarding the
Game of Thrones finale during the
trailer he will face a trial the dragon
pet and he'll be sentenced to death and
this time he will not get away with it
a few days ago we received even more
details surrounding this shocking end
for many fans favorite character Tyrion
Lannister the source this time is freaky
doctor in Java who even though have
different sources receive the same plot
or should I say the match information in
case you don't know freaky doctor the
source of this major spoiler is the same
source that leaked the entire season 7
plot which turned out to be hundred
percent accurate so all the potential
spoilers you're going to hear in this
video will likely turn out to be true so
if you don't want anything spoiled it's
time for you to close this video these
are major spoilers ok not only do we
have more info regarding turns trial and
we get to know what he's actually gonna
be executed for it's not only for Easter
betrayal or Danny but we also have areas
near death as well as two mysterious
characters appearing at a trial one of
whom is probably going to be long varied
character finally reappearing let's take
a look at what's been added Tyrion is
taking a walk with John and our sink is
landing this is before trial and it's
the aftermath of destruction of the city
their lifeless bodies everywhere a lot
of innocent people the camera pans to
Tyrion showing him horrified thinking to
himself what have I done
ok let's stop right there as most of you
probably know at this point the
production of Game of Thrones has for
the very first time instead of filming
his landing scenes into browning decided
to rather make a huge King's Landing set
in Belfast inside a set streets of
famous Dubrovnik landmark has been
faithfully reproduced fit city gates and
the King's Landing don't many of us had
been wondering why did I bother to
Billis tarry buildings to resemble the
city they used for King's Landing all
these years instead of simply filming an
actual medieval Old Town's as they
usually did Britain later found out that
it's because game utterance is not
allowed to burn the city to the ground
the set was shortly after being created
burned down with a huge bridge between
demolish towers the city gate has been
obliterated in towers that once
protected as he had fallen in flaming
dome has been burned down as well
all these leaked photos served as a
final confirmation that the capital is
most definitely going to fall and big
portion of it is going to burn down in
the final season however we could not
tell anything more than that who did it
why some speculated including myself its
Dragon Fire because the show bill to
King's Landing said mainly to do live
art techniques and Dragon firing game
appearance is portrayed by live art
techniques
some also speculated the math been
certainly in stir bringing them all with
wildfire it's all been speculations and
theories but now we have leaked plot of
the game of Thrones finale and it does
answer all the questions we've had who
burned it tyrion is responsible for the
burning of insulin again no there are no
white survived Walker's inside the city
walls and is burning to place why he did
it
Durin's main and young objective was to
kill the people of King's Landing all 1
million of them Terrans objective was to
avoid the city population from turning
into whites in other words theorem
probably thought the night King would
end up taking the capital so he decided
to burn it and it's 1 million population
in order to prevent the 19 from creating
a huge army that will probably be hard
to defeat at that point many will die
including some main characters Covino
will certainly survive all the
characters were being on Tyrion's trial
brain sensei yara robinson Brienne great
warmth I was sent to mysterious
characters out of those not present on a
trial miss sandy John and Danny are also
live at this point but are somewhere
else
John has even taken a walk with Tyrion
earlier in this episode among the
survivors is Arya Stark will also attend
the trial but she almost met her end
during the destruction arias caught in
the fire of King's Landing but manages
the escapes arrived the Tyrion confessed
his guilt while taking a walk with John
in Daoists across the demolished capital
did the horrified looked here and had
vile overlooking all the lifeless bodies
of all the innocent people gave him away
it's Brandon history at raven skills
that's going to be an N for Tyrion the
source says that bran has a talk with
Sansa brains the one who tells of
Tarrance betrayal twitter's Tyrion will
then be imprisoned and put on her trial
how I see it happening is Jon and I was
showing Tyrion all the lifeless bodies
of thousands of innocent people
basically showing him what he has done
and then at the end of the road they
reveal to him that they know it's him
who caused it imprisoning him and
locking him down in the charge of a
trial it's ER Davos Seaworth his judge
accompany they told Starks sensorium
brain stark
they're also similarily Brienne of Tarth
Robin Arryn you're agree forming two new
characters one of them wearing a golden
armor previously it's only been known
that Tyrion is being at her trial for
betraying the neighbors family but now
we know it's not only that he's also
burned down the capital and most of its
population Tyrion is a traitor in his
being judged in the game of Thrones
finale he's betrayed Aniyah is sided
with his family and this should not come
as a huge surprise
Tyrion's been preventing house lannister
from falling during the entire past
season because of Tyrion in his war
planes Dany has lost most of realized
and
strength has drastically decreased
Durance plans also resulted with the
food and the gold being unprotected and
basically left for Cersei to take it
which she did throughout his meeting
with Cersei Tyrion even confess that
he's the one prove anyhow lynnster from
falling you've convinced about on before
I was working towards the same goal the
Kogi were towards your entire sea I
didn't know action at this family I am
no warden preventing that from happening
Daenerys didn't want to debate and
negotiate she didn't want to bring new
words she wanted to bring you fire and
blood until I advised her otherwise I
don't want to destroy our family I never
have Tyrion and Cersei made a deal on
their meeting exactly when the camera
cut away and it's tearing who told
Cersei to promise John and they need the
help in the world's to come
Tyrion realized Circe is pregnant and
he's probably working to put that
lannister on the throne ensuring his
house his future how else could you
explain why Cersei just moments ago
refused to help them in the war against
the dead only to be later after her
meeting with Tyrion came back at the
dragon pit and promised Danny to aid
them even though she will not why would
she change your mind all the sudden
Tyrion and Cersei was not going to go
north as she said herself to all of them
a bit earlier and so he told her to lie
about it for now
Tyrion told her to make a false promise
of supporting them with the troops and
at fey buy more time to improve her
armies
anyway it's back to the child bran stark
will use his greenside powers during
this trial and take us back to the first
season brain will recall something
Turner said to his mother Catelyn Stark
in the first season
it's Tyrion statement that he would
never bet against his family there's
another thing we know Jen will say they
deserve it implying that the people of
King's Landing deserve to die Tyrion is
full of anger the most dramatic moment
of the trial will be Tyrion falling on
his knees in the middle of speech check
down by his actions he also won't be
able to ask for a child by comment it's
unknown how Tyrion will be executed
because unlike the trial his death was
not filmed in Seville but in studio we
also know there will not be much of a
snow at the dragon pit as most of it
already melted down at this point of the
season meaning that winter is most
likely over by the time Tyrion is being
under trial there's one more info but
it's more of a rumor than a legit leak
it says that while Tyrion is being
judged Winterfell is being reconstructed
miss sandy John and Danny are not at
trial my guess would be the Danis giving
birth to John child and that's exactly
where me sandy and John are with
why would John baby Danny instead of
attending a trial but he really has to
be with her well then his mother died
giving birth to her John's mother also
died giving birth to him and even to his
mother for that matter died giving birth
to him as well so actually one can see
why John has to be with Danny during the
childbirth but let's get a bit back into
the trial there are two mysterious
characters the first one is a person
wearing a golden attire a tyrannous
trial most likely Dornish clothes freaky
doctors sent a picture of Oberyn to one
of his sources and he said that his
style matched the person should be
represented David thorne it'll be this
characters first appearance on the show
but it's probably character death should
be known to the book readers the other
mr. character is a bit older guy with a
short beard wearing a green attire he
might be Howland Reed it's a character
most of us have been waiting for a long
time to reappear it's a popular theory
that he will in fact be the one to
reveal the truth of Jon Snow I'm
introduced with Holland and his
importance in the Game of Thrones
Howland Reed is the man whose children
Meera and Jojen played an important role
in brain star's life since if not for
damn brain probably would not ever have
become a three-eyed raven he would have
probably been dead Holland is a man who
saved Ned from a certain death saved and
Stark who gave his best but could not
stand a chance against her Archer day in
superior fighting skills Barry knows
about John's parentage due to his
ability of having visions of the past
and Sam knows it from the books he's
read but Helen Reed was actually there
how and witness John's birth and that is
violence seem not appearing in the final
season Holland truly is the one to
reveal John's identity to him I think he
might even do it without being the one
to actually tell him that it could still
be Ned who will really - John just as he
promised he would but not in person but
rather through Holland in the scene from
the very first season and their parting
letter tells John that he's a stark in
that while he does not read his name he
is his blood John is about his matter
who are she and if she's still alive
Nathan was the John that one day he will
tell him the truth about his mother
but since Ned is not alive there's no
way Ned could fulfill his promise or is
there if Game of Thrones has taught us
anything throughout these seven seasons
is the Ned Stark is a man of his word if
Ned made a promise he will keep it and
there's actually this one promise Ned
has yet to fulfill that might be dead
but it doesn't mean that he will not
fulfill his last promise and be the one
to reveal the truth to John Snow the
truth which would say I'm brain and
maybe even Holland confirm sure bran
could share what is seen in his vision
or Sam could showing what his red or
even Howland Reed
could tell the truth as he witnessed in
himself but the only way for the
revelation to have its full effect is
for John to discover it on his own to
the most important person in his life at
art stark don't get me wrong here all
three brands salmon Howland or at least
some of them will definitely play in
poor role in this huge revelation as I
definitely see them confirming to John
the truth he'll find out through his
father Ned Stark I can definitely see
how in coming with Ned Stark's letter in
which all the revelations are written
and John actually gets to find it out
from each true father I believe the
other person wearing the colors of house
read is Howland Reed himself there you
have guys new and updated shocking plot
of the game in terms finale
Jamie save the city from the Mad King
and will possibly save it from Cersei as
well during the final season but he will
not be able to save it from his brother
Tyrion Lannister who will decide to burn
everything and everyone down
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace
[Music]